[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER PERSON: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for coming.
My name is Jen Person.
I'm a developer advocate at
Google for the Firebase team,
and I am so thrilled for
you to be part of this,
my first talk as a Googler.
Um, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I really can't think
of a better place to do it.
I hope you've had as
much fun as I have.
I've seen some really great
talks and some really awesome
trainings and met
some of you, and I
hope to meet some more of you.
So thanks so much
for being here.
So what I want to talk
to you about today
is incorporating Firebase
into your existing app.
So what I found is talking
to other developers
at conferences, you may like
the idea of incorporating
the Firebase database or
storage or authentication,
but a lot of developers already
have an existing app that
has all those things
in it, so they
think Firebase isn't for them.
But I'm here to tell you that
there are some features that
are still very useful for
incorporating your app,
especially to grow
your user base.
So I'm going to talk
about two main topics.
One is app quality, and
another is app growth.
I find that when deciding
what to talk about,
these things really went
hand-in-hand for me,
because a lot of what
makes an app grow
has to include a quality app.
People aren't
going to be sharing
their app with their
friends and telling them
about it if it's crashing.
So I'll briefly spend
a little time talking
about the Firebase features
that can help with your app's
performance and
your app quality,
and then I'll talk about some
of our app growth options.
So according to a study of
one and two star reviews,
nearly half of
the complaints are
related to problems
developers can address.
So crashes and
performance-- exactly what
I was talking about.
And since we all tend to want
to be informed consumers,
we tend to look at
our reviews first.
I don't know about
you, but I have not
bought anything for
the past, let's say,
five years without looking
at the reviews first.
So definitely poor reviews
can curb your app's growth.
So with that in mind, let's
take a look at the app
I'm going to use as a sample
to incorporate Firebase.
And it's called
Friendly Translate,
and if you've done any
of our code labs before,
you know that we love
things that are friendly.
It uses the Google
Cloud Translation
API to translate from a
couple of different languages,
and it doesn't use
Firebase, at least not yet.
So I'll show you
Friendly Translate.
And here it is, so simple
interface, looks a little bit
like another translate
app that you may know,
has some languages to
choose from, and it--
I am glad you are here.
Now you're going
to see how bad I am
at texting on a small screen.
But yeah, that's all
there is to my app.
So even though I have this
totally awesome Translate app,
it is certainly possible it can
have some not so great reviews.
So what do I do if
I'm getting reviews
like these in the App Store
or the Google Play Store?
These really aren't
unlike reviews
you may have seen for
other apps before.
I even did like a very quick
search of the App Store
and found one that
sounds like it could even
pertain to something like this.
Like reading other reviews, I
realize that it's not just me.
It's been at least a
month or so since I
tried using the app on
my iPad, but I couldn't,
because it crashed instantly.
It's worked for me in the past.
That was awhile ago.
Again, definitely
not something you
would want potential
users to be reading.
So sometimes reviews will tell
you exactly what's going on,
but you may not know why
users dislike your app.
So Firebase has a bunch
of features to help.
I'm going to take a look at
each one of those reviews
I just showed you,
and then show you
how a Firebase feature could
help you address that issue
and, thus, help you
grow your user base.
Let's look at this one.
"Always crashing."
We see these ones
a lot, and they
can have a huge effect on
how your app is received.
And so even though I
know what the problem is,
this really doesn't
help narrow it down.
If I have some sort
of crash that I
didn't catch in my
initial testing,
it can be tough to do so if
I haven't already found it.
So Firebase provides a
couple different resources
for reporting and
prioritizing crashes
that are happening in your app.
So Firebase Crash Reporting
has been around for awhile,
and Firebase developers like it.
And I imagine you've
heard that Google recently
acquired Fabric, which
provides Crashlytics,
which is another option
for crash reporting.
In fact, if you go to the
Firebase console right now,
and you haven't registered
any crashes yet,
this is the screen
that you'll see.
And it's pretty
clear from what's
written that Firebase is
advocating to use Crashlytics
if you haven't used one already.
It's even like a
slightly different color.
But there are still
reasons you may
want to use one or the other.
No matter which
option you choose,
just know that Firebase will
help developers migrate easily
to a final solution
that combines
the best of both of these.
If you're developing
in an Android app,
in fact, you could
just incorporate both.
In iOS, you do have to choose.
So while there are good
reasons for both of them,
I wanted to try out
Crashlytics, so that's
what I'm going to show you
today for my crash reporter.
Crashlytics is the world's
fastest crash reporter.
I'll even show you
what that looks like.
It combines similar
issues and shows priority
to help you find and
resolve problems quickly.
And you can minimize the impact
of your crashes for your users
by focusing on the ones that
are impacting the most of them.
And it's available
on iOS and Android.
Now Firebase-- oh, pardon.
Crashlytics will give me
deep insights into what's
crashing in my
app, and it'll even
send me email notifications,
which I can set up what kind
of notifications I want to get.
Here we can see already
there's been some sort of crash
in Friendly Translate.
So let's take a look at
just how fast Crashlytics
reports on crashes.
I happen to know that
there is a crash in my app,
and I'm going to make it
crash for you right now,
and we'll take a look at
Crashlytics shortly after.
OK.
So here, I have my app.
Change my language.
Oh, here we go.
Yes.
Friendly Translate crashed.
So after a moment, we'll be
able to see that in the console,
and we have our crash reported.
So there we go.
So it really is that fast.
You can really find
out what's going
on in your app in real time,
and because it aggregates
those different crashes, you
can see what those trends are.
Now what about a
review like this one?
"The app worked quickly
for me on my new device
in my fast office Wi-Fi."
This is something that
you may have heard before,
but depending on where
your users are located
or what kind of
devices they're using,
they may not have
that same experience.
And certainly, you
can try to test
in several different scenarios,
but you will not necessarily
catch very specific
issues that way.
So I can monitor and address
such performance issues
using Firebase for
Performance Monitoring,
and it gives you
actionable insights
into your app's performance
from your user's point of view.
And it was released in
beta at I/O this year.
Performance
Monitoring can tell us
how the app performs from
your user's perspective,
and it runs in the production
version of your app
with minimal overhead.
So you can rest
assured that it's not
bogging down your app
in the process of trying
to improve it.
So Performance Monitoring offers
a couple of features right out
of the box--
automatic tracing-- and you can
create custom traces and also
automatic HTTP and
HTTP/S metrics.
So a trace is a report
for a period of time
that is going to have a
defined beginning and end.
And there are some that are done
automatically like a cold app
start, how long your app
is in the foreground,
and how long it's
in the background.
HTTP and HTTP/S
traffic metrics include
response time,
which is going to be
from the moment of invocation to
the final byte that's received,
payload size in bytes,
and success rate.
So it's going to take a
look at your status codes
like 200 types being
successful and 500 type errors.
And it's going to
help you narrow down
if there's a specific
server or network
issue that's causing that.
It also includes URL
pattern globbing,
so again, you're sort of
aggregating the different URLs
so that all of these will be
considered the same structure.
So that gives you
an aggregated view
of how your APIs are performing.
And the transaction
metrics it includes
are app version, device,
country, OS level, carrier,
and radio, which
I'll show you what
that looks like in the console.
Now this is a sample of an app
that is live and uses Firebase
Performance Monitoring.
And what I want to briefly
show you, besides the traces,
including the defaults
and the custom traces,
is that deep insight you can
get into network requests.
So here, if I want
to find out more
about what kind of
response time I'm getting,
I can have it,
again, broken down
by how long each
carrier has taken
and the app version
and what device it's on
to really narrow down if I'm
having some trend in an issue.
Sometimes it can be
just a single carrier
that's causing it,
and this really
helps you narrow it down.
So sometimes user feedback
is not particularly helpful.
Very few of your users are going
to be leaving that feedback,
so there's the possibility
that they're not even reporting
the issues that they're having.
They're just
uninstalling your app.
So how can we find out more
about what the users like
and don't like about our app?
That's where Google Analytics
for Firebase comes in.
And what I love about Google
Analytics for Firebase
is that it's free and unlimited.
So you have this out-of-the-box
solution when you incorporate
Firebase into your app that
gives you reporting on up
to 500 distinct events, and
you can have custom events with
custom parameters, and you
can view all of that data,
including how it connects up
to other Firebase features.
For instance, if you
use crash reporting,
you can incorporate that
into your analytics,
take a look at your
dynamic links performance,
notifications,
in-app purchase data,
and see how your
campaigns are performing.
Next feature I want to talk
about is Remote Config.
This is another feature that
works well with Analytics
to really help you narrow
down what people may really
enjoy about your app, what they
may like and not like about it,
and helps you give a custom
experience to your users.
So Remote Config lets you change
the behavior and appearance
of your app without
pushing an update,
so you don't have to depend
on your users to do so,
because if they're
anything like me,
there's at least 12 updates
that need to be done,
and especially if
you have something
important like a
crash that you want
to resolve by
removing some feature,
you don't want to have to
wait for them to update it.
You can use the Firebase console
to override default values,
so you can have default values
for different scenarios,
including user properties
that you can set up,
app versions, operating
systems, audiences that you
define in Firebase Analytics.
It's really up to you to how you
want to segment and customize
how you send out that
different configuration.
So, for instance, you could
change your app's color theme
to match a seasonal
promotion or change
the start date of the sale.
Or I can use Remote Config
to change what the default
language is going to be.
On the one hand, it's possible
that in a certain country,
they may want to start
with whatever language is
native to that area, or
maybe a lot of people using
the app in the
area are visiting,
and they want to translate
something into that language.
So depending on
where somebody lives,
you may want to have a
different default language.
So here, I can use Remote Config
to change what the default
language is and use the region
where the device is located
to decide which
language is shown
as being the original one.
Come up and check it
out later, because I'm
pretty excited about that
one, and I'll show it to you.
So according to a study
by Localytics in 2016,
an average of 23% of
users abandon an app
after just one use.
So those few first moments that
a user interacts with an app
are critical, and you
don't want to become
part of those statistics.
So Firebase provides
some great tools
to make the user's
first experience as
easy and enjoyable as possible.
And the ones I want to talk
to you about a little bit
are App Invites
and Dynamic Links.
Also, to go with App Invites and
Dynamic Links, 82% of Americans
ask for recommendations
from friends and family,
and that's even higher, 92%,
for 18 to 34-year-olds, which
is why these features
are so powerful.
So App Invites allow you to
share referral codes or content
via SMS or email, and it really
is an out-of-the-box solution
that enables you to send
invites from your actual users
to their friends and who can
give better recommendations
than people who
already enjoy your app.
And then with just
a few lines of code,
you can have that set up
to send out those invites.
And this can include
Dynamic Links,
so rather than just
going to, let's say,
the default page in your app, if
there's some specific contents
that that user would
be most interested in,
you can have a link that sends
them there and even survives
the install process.
So let's say you've fixed
your performance issues,
you've resolved your
crashes, and you've
made it a much
better experience.
How do you reengage
those users that haven't
touched your apps in a while?
Firebase Cloud Messaging
makes it super easy.
So Google Cloud Messaging sends
out so many messages every day,
and they are nearly
instant and very reliable.
Firebase Cloud Messaging
makes it really easy
to send out messages that are
directed to specific groups
rather than just spamming
messages to all of your users.
Let's say that this particular
user-- in this case, me--
is not very interested
in using the app anymore,
because every time I try to
pick my favorite language,
it crashes.
But now that crash
has been resolved.
I can send a message
to a specific group.
It can be based on
properties or events,
and I can just say, come
back to Friendly Translate.
And there we are.
Come back to Friendly Translate.
It invites me to come back.
And it doesn't have to be
a simple message like that.
It can include custom links
to get you right to the place
where you want them
to be in your app.
Just a simple example.
So again, you can use Firebase
Cloud Messaging to invite
users to drive user
engagement, invite them back
to use your app.
You can send messages all the
way down to a single device,
groups of devices.
You can have topics that
they are subscribed to.
There are endless possibilities
to reengage your users
and, again, without
spamming them
by making it simple for you
to choose specifically who
that notification pertains to.
There we go.
And there is one
last demo that I
wanted to show you that
incorporates Analytics using
Cloud Functions for
Firebase, because I
am a huge fan of Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
If any of you have
seen my videos,
you know I love to
talk about them,
and I couldn't help
but include an example.
So I just want to
briefly show you
some code with how you
can incorporate Analytics
events to respond to things
users do to reengage them
with your app.
So what I've done here
is create an event
that is triggered when
the app is removed.
And again, this occurs
in the server side
and not in your user's app.
And so in order to have
this event trigger,
just make sure that if
you're using Analytics Events
Triggers for Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
it has to be a conversion event.
So you may have to
go into the console
and make sure it's triggered
as a conversion event.
So if an Android
user removes the app,
you can log that event, or
it is logged automatically.
And you can send them an email,
and you can invite them back
to use your app.
Now, in this case, I
wrote out verbatim.
I wrote out specifically
for each language.
You could even incorporate
the translate API
here as well if you
wanted to make sure
that you are translating
custom to whatever location
the user is at, what
language they would be using.
But in this case, I figured
it may make sense to hard code
something, because if some
sort of faulty translation
is the reason that they
stop using your app,
you wouldn't want to
incorporate that here as well.
You'd want to make
sure that everything
was translated in a way
that looked right to them.
In this case, I don't
speak all these languages,
so they might actually not
be the best translations.
So again, using the--
I'm sending them an
email, logging the event.
That way, anytime a user
decides to leave my app,
I can invite them
back, and I can even
give them some sort of discount
or motivation to come back.
So after making some
great changes to my app,
it seems like people
like it a lot more now.
Five stars-- would
translate again.
And it translates so fast.
And so easy to use and fun.
So these are all features
that you can incorporate
into your app, even if it's
already up and running,
and that's actually the
best time to use them,
to really get your
idea out there.
I mean, you've
already spent the time
to build something and
come up with a great idea.
Why not really make sure that
the users who would enjoy it
are actually getting to see it?
So here's a summary of the
features that I added--
Crashlytics, Performance
Monitoring, Remote Config,
Firebase Cloud Messaging, App
Invites and Dynamic Links,
and because I can't help myself
but talk about Cloud Functions,
I also included a
brief example of using
Cloud Functions for
Firebase with Node Mailer
to mail out messages
whenever a user on Android
removes the app
from their phone.
So thank you all
so much for coming,
and I hope you are having a
great time here at GDD Europe,
and I hope to see you next year.
I'm Jen Person.
I will be upstairs
for Office Hours
if anyone has any additional
questions about these features
or anything else
Firebase related.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]